hey this is press tow
Walker parents were divided when the
reporter Mark Tai of the Sunday
independent shared this child's
mathematical
homework the question is how many
corners does a semicircle have the child
has put the answer of two and it is
marked Incorrect and the correct answer
is said to be zero so people were
wondering what is the correct answer
is it zero or is it
two now I will suggest that both of
these answers have justification you
could also say the answer is infinite
and I'm going to explain why three could
be a valid answer
too so how is that possible let's get to
that in a minute so I posted this
question on YouTube in the community Tab
and I found these results in the poll
over 31,000 of you submitted votes on
Thanksgiving Day I'm so happy that
people were thinking about mathematics
on Thanksgiving help me settle an
argument how many corners does a
semicircle have 9% replied zero an
overwhelming 75% of the votes were for
two 1% of people said three 10% said
infinite and 5% said all of the above
can be correct count me in that category
now some people may nitpick and say well
this is not a properly defined question
so there is no answer so what's the
point of even thinking about this
question I will recall a quote by the
statistician George EP
box all models are wrong but some are
useful this refers to the fact that
basically anything we do in statistics
or science is just an an idealized
version of reality the model of geometry
on a flat plane is what we do most of
our calculations but we know this is
wrong because SpaceTime is curved we do
calculations with the ideal gas law but
these are idealized conditions which are
not met in reality the models are wrong
but they can still be
useful just think about a weather report
and how we talk about temperature now
temperature is a reflection of the
average kinetic energy so you can either
have more kinetic energy or less kinetic
energy there is no such thing as cold it
is actually heat that is leaving your
body however a weather forecaster might
say that tomorrow will be cold or a cold
front is coming in or don't let the cold
air inside the home this is a wrong
model but it can still be
useful so in this question how exactly
do we get to a corner of a semicircle we
first start out with the definition of a
circle a circle is the locus of points
that are some fixed distance from the
center point it is just this boundary
which is the circle if you wanted to
have all points in between this would be
more accurately called a dis so a
semicircle would be half of a circle so
it would just be this half Arc
if you wanted to enclose this area by
connecting the diameter this would be
more accurately called a half
dis so we now State the question how
many corners are there in a half
dis but what is a
corner here's the definition from
Wikipedia for vertex in geometry in
Geometry a Vertex plural vertices or
vertexes is a point where two or more
curves lines or edges meet or
intersect as a consequence of this
definition the point where two lines
meet to form an angle and the corners of
polygons and polyhedra are
vertices so where does this definition
bring
us in the half disk we have a straight
edge and we have a curved
Edge if you take a corner to be only
where two straight edges meet it is
right to say there are zero Corners to a
half dis this is a justifiable model you
could also say a corner is where two
edges of any kind meet whether it's a
straight edge or a curved Edge and in
this case it would obviously be two
corners this is a justifiable answer in
fact for all practical purposes this is
probably a really good answer imagine
you have a coffee table that's in the
shape of a half moon or a half
circle you might be worried that someone
might run into these sharp Corners there
are two sharp Corners to this table so
you could say there are Corners to this
shape now let's take a look at another
interpretation let's start out with the
triangle where the base is a diameter
and one point is going to approximate
this circular Arc this shape obviously
has three
corners we can increase this to a
quadrilateral which definitely has four
corners then we can increase this to a
pentagon then we can increase it to a
hexagon we can increase it to a heptagon
and an octagon a nonagon and a
decagon by this point we have 10 sides
and 10 corners and we're getting a lot
closer to the shape of a
semicircle let's imagine in increasing
the number of corners and we continue
going
up once we get to about a 100 Corners
the shape is visually indistinguishable
from the half dis that we want to
represent so you could say that the
semicircle will be a shape that's
represented as the number of Corners
goes to
Infinity the semicircle itself doesn't
have an infinite number of Corners
however this will become a useful model
for us to understand how many corners
there are in the
semicircle so we've gone over the
obvious answers of 0o 2 and
infinity where does the answer of three
come from this comes from the world of
graphic design here's a help page from
Adobe Illustrator the first thing is
what is a path a path contains one or
more straight or curved line segments
that you draw on a canvas using the pen
pencil or curvature tool you can have
different types of paths a straight open
path a curved open path a straight Clos
path or a curv Clos path and you'll see
the final shape is exactly that of the
half dis or the semicircle that we're
trying to
analyze now what are anchor points
anchor points are points that control
the shape and direction of the path the
anchor points on the end points of a
path they're called control handles or
Corner points Corner points can be
straight or curved points depending on
the shape they join so if you look at
this half dis there are exactly three
Corner points it's the two points on the
end and this one point that's in the
center so it does make sense to speak of
the Three Corner points of this
semicircle and that's why three is a
completely valid answer if you're
dealing with the world of graphic design
so I hope this gives a perspective on
why zero 2 infinity and three could be
justifiable answers to this
question thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions or we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time